يشارك ممرض سان فرانسيسكو الذي أصيب
بفيروس كورونا ما فعلته
بجسده بعد دخوله المستشفى لمدة
ستة أسابيع ، وهو مايك شولتز
قبل شهر تقريبًا من مرضه على اليسار
بالطبع ثم على اليمين في
جناح الإنعاش بعد عدة أسابيع
أخبر BuzzFeed أنه قبل أن يمرض ، كان يمارس الرياضة
كل يوم تقريبًا وكان يتمتع
بصحة جيدة ويبلغ وزنه 190 رطلاً ، فهو الآن 140
رطلاً وقدرة رئته تعود ببطء ،
لكن الأمر استغرق حقًا من
خلال هذا قال شولتز إنه شعر
بالضعف الشديد لدرجة أنه  بالكاد يمكن أن يمسك
الهاتف لالتقاط تلك الصورة على
اليمين وعندما استيقظ اعتقد
أنه كان في المستشفى لمدة أسبوع واحد فقط
عندما كان في المستشفى لستة أعوام ،
فهذا ليس فقط الفيروس الذي
يعيش في وحدة العناية المركزة  صعب جدًا على
الجسم وقد عرفنا منذ فترة طويلة
أن هناك حالة تسمى الضعف المرتبط بوحدة العناية المركزة
التي تحدث عندما
يطول الناس على جهاز التنفس الصناعي
وعادةً بالطريقة التي يتم وضعهم بها في وحدة
طبية  غيبوبة مستعصية على جهاز التنفس الصناعي
لأنه ليس إحساسًا لطيفًا أن
تضطر إلى العيش ومن ثم
يحدث شيئان كبيران أحدهما هو أن تحصل على
شيء يسمى حالة تقويضية حيث
يبدأ جسمك فعليًا في التحول إلى
العضلات للحصول على الوقود ، لذا تبدأ في
تحطيم عضلاتك  والثاني هو
إلغاء التكييف ، فأنت تعلم أنك في
راحة تامة ،
فأنت لا تتحرك ، وبالتالي
تصبح عضلاتك ضعيفة للغاية ،
وفي نهاية ذلك ما يحدث هو
ما سيصفه والد زوجي في كنتاكي.
ضعيفًا مثل قطة
صغيرة وليس لديك طاقة متبقية
للتحرك لأنك قمت
بالفعل بإزالة معظم قوة عضلاتك
خلال ذلك الوقت أثناء وجودك
في السرير